YOU HAPPENED INTO THE NBA FINALS
EDITION OF THE GROUP CHAT LIVE
ON THE "BLEACHER REPORT" APP
PRESENTED BY FANDUEL.
IT'S CRAZY HOW LOUDEMBE OF THE S
FROM THE BAY AREA, SALUTE TO
GREG IVORY.
WELCOME TO YOU BOTH.
>> HELLO.
>> ALL RIGHT, SO, LISTEN,
MILWAUKEE HAS WON THREE GAMES IN
A ROW.
TOTALLY TURNED THE SERIES
AROUND.
TONIGHT IT'S GAME SIX OF THE NBA
FINALS IN MILWAUKEE.
G-MONEY, WHAT DO YOU GOT FOR THE
PEOPLE?
>> WE'VE BEEN GIVING AWAY FREE
KICKS AT ALL OF OUR SHOWS AND
I'M NOT DONE.
WE'RE GIVING AWAY UP TO 5K IN
SNEAKERS TODAY AND WE'RE GIVING
OUT A TOTAL OF SIX, ERIN, SIX,
CABBIE, SIX, SIX, SIX, SIX $250
SNEAKER GIFT CARDS TO PUT
TOWARDS WHATEVER KICKS YOU GUYS
IN THE AUDIENCE WANT.
I'M GIVING OUT THREE PAIRS RIGHT
HERE ON THE SHOW.
I'M GIVING OUT ANOTHER PAIR ON
B/R BETTING SOCIAL, ANOTHER PAIR
ON THE B/ARE R APP, AND I'M NOT
DONE.
I'VE GOT ANOTHER PAIR ON B/R
KICKS.
I LIKE TO START THE SHOW OFF
WITH AN ALLEY-OOP TO SOMEBODY IN
THE AUDIENCE, SO GET IN THE
COMMENTS AND TELL US, WHAT KICKS
WOULD YOU BUY?
IF I WAS TO GIVE YOU SOME MONEY,
WHAT KICKS ARE YOU GOING OUT
THERE TO GO PURCHASE RIGHT NOW?
AND I'M GIVING OUT A PAIR OF
KICKS TO A LUCKY FAN WHO GIVES
ME AN INTERESTING TAKE.
>> HOLD ON, GREG.
BEFORE YOU DO THAT, I DON'T KNOW
IF YOU SAW THIS ON B/R KICKS,
BUT ON SUNDAY THEY POSTED THIS
VIDEO FROM P.J. TUCKER GIVING
AWAY A PAIR OF SNEAKERS.
>> THIS WAS SO SWEET.
>> TO HIS ASSISTANT TRAINER,
MICHELLE.
THIS IS DOPE.
P.J. TUCKER, HE IS THE SNEAKER
GOD.
THREE YEARS IN A ROW HE'S WON
THE SNEAKER GOD TITLE FROM B/R
KICKS.
HEY, SALUTE TO P.J. TUCKER.
SUCH A GOOD DUDE.
ERIN, IF YOU HAVEN'T PICKED UP A
PAIR OF ONES LIKE MICHELLE JUST
GOT, WHAT'S IN YOUR SUMMER
ROTATION?
>> SO I HAVE SOME OFF-WHITE
KICKS, SOME KICKS SHOES, I LOVE
VEJAS AS WELL.
BUT HONESTLY I KEEP IT ALL WHITE
DURING THE SUMMER.
>> KIND OF KEEP IT FRESH.
AND YOU'VE GOT TO KEEP THEM
CLEAN, TOO, AND BE WARY OF THE
CREASE IN THE TOE.
BUT, ANYWAY, G-MONEY, LISTEN,
I'M HERE ON THE WEST COAST.
I JUST PICKED UP A PAIR OF VANS.
WHEN I'M ON THE EAST COAST, I
STICK TO THE J'S.
YOU'RE A WEST COAST DUDE.
ARE YOU ABOUT THE VANS LIFE?
YOU PICKED UP A PAIR OF
VALENCIAS THE OTHER DAY, DIDN'T
YOU?
>> I HAVE TO GO GRAB SOME
VALENCIAS THE OTHER DAY.
BUT THE YEEZIES JUST CAME IN THE
MAIL.
>> DO YOU WEAR THEM?
>> NO, NO, THE MONO, THE
YEEZIES, THEY'RE NOT THE SLIDES.
THEY'RE ACTUALLY THE 350s.
>> G-MONEY, DO YOU GET TO GO TO
THE LISTENING PARTY IN VEGAS
WHEN YOU'RE HERE?
>> NO, KANYE DIDN'T SEND THE
INVITE.
NEXT TIME WE'LL PUT IT TOGETHER.
IT'S ALL GOOD.
HEY, BUT IN THE COMMENTS,
THOUGH, THEY'RE LISTING OFF A
WHOLE BUNCH OF TAKES IN THE
COMMENTS.
LET ME JUST SAY A COUPLE OF
THEM.
I'VE GOT AUNT LOST ROOKIE OF THE
YEAR, HE SAYS ROCK IT WITH THE
TAXI 12s.
DEKE GEEK IS IN THERE.
HE SAID AJ 1s, CAN'T GO ANY
OTHER WAY.
I THINK HE'S SAYING THE JORDAN.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU, DEKE GEEK.
CABBIE, I THINK IT'S TIME, I
THINK IT'S TIME TO GIVE AWAY
SOME SNEAKERS, AND I HAVE --
HOLD ON JUST A SECOND, JUST A
SECOND.
I HAVE NAMELESS.
NAMELESS IS SHOUTING OUT NIKE.
NOT YET, NAMELESS.
>> NAMELESS GOT A PAIR LAST
WEEK.
>> NO, NO, HE'S NOT -- YEAH,
HE'S NOT WINNING THIS WEEK.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU, NAMELESS.
YOU'RE GOING TO GET A HOODIE.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
I'VE GOT DOWN THE EARTH.
I NEED SOME UNIVERSITY BLUE
DUCKS.
SWITCH IT UP HERE, CABBIE.
DIDN'T GO J'S, DIDN'T GO
LeBRONS.
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING?
>> THE NORTH CAROLINA COLORS,
RIGHT?
I THINK THOSE ARE WHAT THOSE
ARE.
>> I THINK SO.
THE UNIVERSITY BLUES.
SHOUT OUT TO MY GUY DOWN THE
EARTH, YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH
THE FIRST $250 IN SNEAKERS
MONEY.
>> WELL, LISTEN, HE CAME FROM
THE HEAVENS AND NOW HE'S PLAYING
ON EARTH.
THE GREEK GOD HAS BEEN
RESPONSIBLE FOR TWO OF THE MOST
MEMORABLE PLAYS IN THE NBA
FINALS.
A RIDICULOUS BLOCK ON DEANDRE
AYTON IN GAME FOUR.
THE GREEK GOD IS ON, GIANNIS ANT
APPOINTMEN
ANTETOKOUNMPO HAS BEEN
ACTIVATED.
WE ASKED YOU HOW MANY POINTS IN
GAME SIX?
I SEE SOME J'S AND AIR MAX 90s.
I KNOW THE COMMENT SECTION IS
FILLED WITH DIFFERENT TAKES.
THE LINE IS 32 1/2 POINTS.
GREG, DO YOU THINK GIANNIS WILL
HAVE HIS WAY WITH PHOENIX'S
DEFENSE TONIGHT, AND WHAT DO
YOUR PEOPLE THINK?
WITH THE WINNERS ONLY ARMY.
>> LET ME ASK THEM, CABBIE.
WHAT I NEED YOU GUYS TO DO IS
GET IN THE COMMENTS AND TELL ME
HOW MANY POINTS GIANNIS IS
PUTTING UP TONIGHT?
AT THE END OF THE GAME WE'LL DM
YOU, WE'LL DM ONE PERSON WHO
GETS THE CLOSEST WITH $250 IN
SNEAKER MONEY.
ERIN, YOU PREDICTED THE SUNS IN
SIX.
YOU PREDICTED THE SUNS IN SIX.
IF THE SUNS ARE TO WIN GAME SIX,
DO YOU THINK GIANNIS IS GOING TO
GO OVER OR UNDER 32 1/2 POINTS?
>> I'M GOING OVER HERE
REGARDLESS OF THE OUTCOME.
GIANNIS IS AVERAGING 32 POINTS
IN THE NBA FINALS SO FAR, 34
POINTS IN MILWAUKEE.
REMEMBER, HE HAD THAT ONE 41
POINT PERFORMANCE IN GAME THREE.
GIANNIS ALSO HIT OVER HIS POINTS
50% ON THE SEASON.
IT'S ALSO GAME SIX.
THEY HAD THE CHANCE TO OBVIOUSLY
WITHIN THE NBA TITLE TONIGHT.
I'M GOING TO HAVE TO GO OVER
32 1/2 POINTS FOR THE GREEK
FREAK TONIGHT.
>> THIS FEELS LIKE IT SHOULD
HIT, BUT THERE'S SO MUCH MORE
PRESSURE ON MILWAUKEE TONIGHT TO
WIN ON THEIR HOME COURT.
BUT REGARDLESS, THERE HAVE BEEN
LIKE FIVE OTHER PLAYERS WHO HAVE
HAD GREAT GAMES IN THE SERIES
AND IT ALMOST FEELS LIKE,
ALMOST, THAT GIANNIS IS AN
AFTERTHOUGHT.
WE MARVEL AT DEVIN BOOKER'S
BACK-TO-BACK 40 POINT GAMES AND
MARVELING AT JRUE HOLIDAY'S
DEFENSE.
THERE ARE PEOPLE IN THE MEDIA
TALKING ABOUT GIANNIS BEING THE
ROBIN TO KHRIS MIDDLETON'S
BATMAN.
STOP IT.
THAT'S RIDICULOUS.
THE CLOSEST COMPARISON IS SHAQ
AND KOBE WHERE SHAQ CARRIED THE
LAKERS FOR THREE-QUARTERS AND
KOBE TOOK OVER IN THE FOURTH.
GIANNIS CARRIES THE BUCKS FOR
LIKE THREE AND A HALF QUARTERS
AND THEN KHRIS GOES TO WORK IN
THE FINAL FIVE AND HE'S BEEN
ELECTRIC.
BUT GIANNIS, I KNOW HE
UNDERSTANDS THIS MOMENT, YOU
KNOW, AS I MENTIONED, THE GREAT
KOBE BRYANT WHO TWEETED A FEW
YEARS AGO, YOU GOT YOUR MVP, AND
THE NEXT STEP IS THE
CHAMPIONSHIP.
THIS WOULD BE AN INCREDIBLE
PROPHETIC WIN FOR BOTH KOBE
BRYANT AND GIANNIS
ANTETOKOUNMPO.
WITH THAT SAID, GIVE ME 33
TONIGHT FOR GIANNIS.
33 POINTS, 14 REBOUNDS, AND AN
EMPHATIC WIN.
BUCKS IN SIX.
LET'S GET IT, GIANNIS.
G-MONEY, ARE YOU ON THE SAME
PAGE AS ERIN AND I WHEN WE SAY
THE OVER TONIGHT FOR THE GREEK
GOD?
>> CABBIE, BEFORE I GIVE MY
TAKE, YOU ALREADY KNOW I'VE GOT
TO TAP IN WITH WINNERS ONLY IN
THE COMMENTS BEFORE I TELL YOU
IF I'M WITH YOU AND ERIN OR NOT.
BUT IN THE COMMENTS, THE
COMMENTS ARE JUMPING.
I'VE GOT HE'S HAVING 37 POINTS
WITH 12 REBOUNDS, 4 ASSISTS.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
REAL EXACT.
HERE WE GO, 35 POINTS, THE
FINALS MVP WITH 11 REBOUND AND 5
ASSISTS.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
I'M GIVING OUT ONE MORE HOODIE.
ONE MORE HOODIE.
I HAVE SPICY DUBS.
SPICY DUBS, HE'S GOING OVER
32 1/2 FOR SURE, AT LEAST 35.
HE'S GOING TO TAKE OVER TONIGHT.
HE'S AVERAGING MORE THAN
EVERYONE RIGHT NOW.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU, SPICY DUBS.
YOU ARE ALSO WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
CABBIE, ERIN, I'M RIGHT THERE
WITH YOU GUYS.
GIANNIS HAS -- HE'S A MAN ON A
MISSION.
HE IS A MAN ON A MISSION.
HE'S BEEN PLAYING REALLY WELL.
SCOTT FOSTER IS THE REFEREE
TONIGHT, CABBIE.
>> OKAY.
>> CHRIS PAUL USUALLY DOESN'T,
YOU KNOW, WIN WHEN SCOTT FOSTER
IS THE REFEREE.
SO I'M FEELING THE VIBE, I'M
FEELING THE VIBES THAT GIANNIS
IS GOING TO HAVE A BIG GAME
TONIGHT.
THERE'S GOING TO BE SOME
CONTROVERSY ON THE OTHER SIDE.
>> DO YOU THINK?
>> HE'S 0-12 WHEN HE'S
REFEREEING IN PLAYOFF GAMES.
>> THAT'S THE WAY.
HEY, THAT'S A FACT RIGHT THERE,
CABBIE.
THAT IS A FACT, WHAT ERIN JUST
SAID.
SO I'M ROCKING WITH GIANNIS,
MAN.
>> BUT, LISTEN, SCOTT BROTHERS
HAS BEEN A REFEREE FOR MANY
YEARS AND HAS REFEREED THOUSANDS
OF GAMES, GUYS.
IT'S NOT JUST LIKE CHRIS PAUL --
>> I FEEL LIKE THIS IS THE
TWITTER CHAT, THOUGH, TODAY, ALL
OVER.
>> YEAH, IT DEFINITELY IS.
CABBIE, DID YOU SEE THE REPORT
THAT THE NBA PUT OUT?
DID YOU SEE THE ACTUAL --
>> I DIDN'T SEE THAT.
>> THE CREW CHIEF, THE CREW
CHIEF IS SCOTT FOSTER.
HE'S THE TOP DOG.
SO HE'S CALLING -- YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT TONY BROTHERS.
NO, NO, SCOTT FOSTER IS THE CREW
CHIEF.
>> FINE.
THEN TONY BROTHERS, HE'S ALSO A
REFEREE.
LISTEN, WE'LL SEE.
>> IN THE COMMENTS, REMEMBER TO
DROP YOUR TAKES IN THE COMMENTS.
AFTER THE GAME WE'LL PICK ONE
WINNER WHO IS CLOSEST TO TAKE
HOME THE $250 IN SNEAKER CASH.
BUT WE ALSO GOT TWO MORE PAIRS
TO GIVE AWAY IN THE SHOW.
SO, CABBIE, LET'S KEEP THIS
THING GOING.
>> ALL RIGHT.
SO SPICY DUBS IS GETTING A PAIR
OF KICKS.
IS THE AVATAR FOR SPICY DUBS
LIKE JAMES WINSTON, WHEN HE WAS
EATING THE DUB A FEW YEARS AGO
IN TAMPA BAY?
IT MADE ME THINK OF THAT.
YOU KNOW WE LOVE OUR QUICK
HITTERS AROUND HERE AND SO DOES
THE FANDUEL CHAIN LEGEND.
JOHN DO DROPPED TEN BANDS ON A
RACE TO TEN IN GAME FIVE AND MY
GUY HIT $18,000 ON A RACE TO TEN
PROP.
I MEAN, THE PAYOUT IS AMAZING.
BUT IMAGINE HAVING TEN BANDS TO
DROP ON A RACE TO TEN.
I LOVE THE CONFIDENCE.
AND SALUTE TO JOHN DO.
WE'VE SEEN HIM MANY TIMES ON B/R
BETTING SOCIAL AND WE FEATURED
HIM A COUPLE TIMES IN THE GROUP
CHAT.
FROM BROOKLYN, NEW YORK.
BUT, LISTEN, THAT'S LEGIT.
RACE TO TEN.
OUR FIRST, THOUGH, IS THE 3X2.
AND IT'S BEING BOOSTED BY OUR
FRIENDS AT FANDUEL FOR THE 3X2
PARLAY, WHICH IS QUITE SIMPLY
WILL THERE BE TWO THREE-POINTERS
MADE IN THE FIRST THREE MINUTES
OF THE THIRD COURT AND TWO IN
THE FIRST THREE MINUTES OF THE
SECOND QUARTER.
PARLAYING, PLUS 410.
THAT IS JUICY.
THE BUCKS AND SUNS COMBINED FOR
THREE-POINTERS AND BOTH TEAMS
SHOT OVER 50%.
YOU KNOW THESE TEAMS CAN LIGHT
IT UP FROM DOWNTOWN.
UNFORTUNATELY, ONLY ONE LEG OF
THE 3X2 HIT IN GAME FIVE.
SO WE NEED A BOUNCEBACK GAME.
TONIGHT FANDUEL IS OFFERING THE
BOOST.
WE SAW THE ODDS, PLUS 410.
BOTH TEAMS HAVE HIT 53
THREE-POINTERS THROUGH FIVE
GAMES.
WE'VE GOT TO GET IT.
G-MONEY, WHO IN THE AUDIENCE IS
RIDING WITH US TODAY?
I'M SAYING OFF THE TOP, I'M
LOCKING IN THE 3X2 PARLAY.
>> LOVE THOSE VIBES, CABBIE.
LOVE THOSE VIBES.
LET ME SEE IF THOSE VIBES ARE
TRANSFERRING TO THE AUDIENCE IN
THE COMMENTS.
WHAT I NEED YOU GUYS TO DO IN
THE COMMENTS, GET IN THERE AND
TELL ME IF THE BY 3 X2 PARLAY
WILL HIT AND WHICH PLAYERS YOU
THINK IS PUTTING THE BALL
THROUGH THE HOOP FOR THE 3X2,
GIVING AWAY $250 IN SNEAKER
MONEY TO MY FAVORITE TAKE.
ERIN, DO YOU THINK WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE A BOUNCEBACK GAME
TONIGHT?
>> YES, OF COURSE.
LAST GAME, THESE TEAMS WERE ON
FIRE FROM THREE.
STILL, THE BUCKS SHOT 50% FROM
BEHIND THE ARC, WHILE THE SUNS
SHOT 68%.
FOR THAT REASON I'M ABSOLUTELY
LOCKING IN THE 3X2 PARLAY
TONIGHT.
IT'S A VALUE AND YOU JUST HAVE
TO TAKE IT.
>> KHRIS MIDDLETON, AND JRUE
HOLIDAY ARE IN THE BAGS RIGHT
NOW.
BOTH ARE GETTING PRAISE FROM THE
MEDIA AND THEY KNOW IT'S THE
FINAL HOME GAME OF THE SEASON.
BROOK LOPEZ HAS BEEN
UNDERWHELMING AT HOME.
HE WENT 1-9 FROM DOWNTOWN IN
GAMES THREE AND FOUR IN
MILWAUKEE AND HE'S NORMALLY A
SOLID DUDE.
HE'S NORMALLY AVAILABLE IN THOSE
CORNERS TO TAKE THOSE THREES.
SO BROOK LOPEZ, WE NEED A
BOUNCEBACK.
ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE COURT,
JAE CROWDER PLAYS BETTER ON THE
ROAD THAN HE DOES AT HOME.
IN GAME THREE MY GUY WENT 6-7
FOR DOWNDOWN.
I'M LOOKING AT JAE CROWDER, JRUE
HOLIDAY.
THOSE PLAYERS ARE GOING TO BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR OUR 3X2 PORARLA.
G-MONEY, WHO ARE THE GUYS YOU'RE
LOOKING AT TO HIT THE PARLAY IN
GAME SIX?
>> THERE'S SHOOTERS ALL OVER THE
COURT.
WE'VE GOT BRIDGES, DON'T FORGET
ABOUT CP3.
MIDDLETON, JRUE HOLIDAY.
THERE'S SHOOTERS ALL OVER.
>> WHO ARE YOUR GUYS, THOUGH?
WHICH GUYS?
ARE YOU GOING TO GIVE ME SEVEN
DUDES?
ARE WE HITTING THE 3X2 MULTIPLE
TIMES?
>> LET ME GET INTO THE COMMENTS
BECAUSE I AM A MAN OF THE
PEOPLE.
CABBIE WANTS ME TO BE SPECIFIC.
LET ME GO BE SPECIFIC IN THESE
COMMENTS, CABBIE.
I'M GIVING AWAY SOME HOODIES
RIGHT NOW.
I'M GIVING AWAY SOME HOODIES.
I'VE GOT BROOK AND BROOK, LOPEZ
AND DEVIN.
OH, I'M SO SORRY.
I'M OVER HERE -- I'M LIKE, HOLD
ON, BROOK?
>> I'M TRYING TO DO THE MATH,
TOO.
IT TOOK ME A SECOND.
>> HEY, THIS IS LIVE.
THIS IS LIVE RIGHT NOW.
YOU GUYS, WE'VE GOT BROOK AND
BOOK, LOPEZ AND DEVIN BOOKER.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU, YOU WALK AWAY
WITH A HOODIE.
I'VE GOT J321.
IT'S AN ELIMINATION DAY, OF
COURSE, HOLIDAY AND BOOKER.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE AS WELL.
CABBIE, THE COMMENTS ARE
JUMPING.
T GIBSON 2 SAYS NO.
WOW, BAD VIBES.
KHRIS STRUGGLES EVERY GAME AND
NO ONE ELSE IS ON THE BUCKS IS
LIKE THAT.
WOULD HAVE TO RELY ON SUNS
PLAYERS AND PAUL DIDN'T THERE
RIGHT NOW.
T GIBSON CAME WITH THE BAD
VIBES.
I'M GOING TO SEND GOOD VIBES TO
YOU, T GIBSON.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
CABBIE AND ERIN, IT IS APPARENT
IF YOU ARE IN THE COMMENTS RIGHT
NOW, THEY ARE LITERALLY JUMPING
TO PEOPLE SAYING YES TO THE 3X2,
SO WE ARE AS A FAMILY ALL RIDING
WITH THE 3X2.
YOU CAN PUT THE YES DOWN FOR ME
BECAUSE YOU KNOW I AM RIDING
WITH THE 3X2.
AND I'M GIVING OUT A PAIR OF
KICKS.
CABBIE, SHOULD I DO IT NOW?
>> IF YOU WANT TO.
I ALSO NEED TO KNOW YOUR
PLAYERS.
I'M INTERESTED IN A LITTLE SIDE
ACTION.
>> OH, MY.
CABBIE WANTS TO KNOW MY PLAYERS.
I'M TRYING TO GIVE OUT SHOES.
CABBIE, ALL RIGHT, I'VE GOT YOU.
PLAYERS, I'M GOING TO GO JRUE
HOLIDAY AND D. BOOKER.
THERE IT IS.
>> THEY'RE JUST GOING TO BE A
PART OF ONE OF THE 3X2s, EITHER
THE FIRST QUARTER OR THIRD
QUARTER?
>> YEAH, JRUE HOLIDAY, D.
BOOKER.
>> OKAY.
>> HERE WE GO.
GIVING OUT $250 RIGHT NOW.
GIVING OUT $250 IN SNEAKER
MONEY.
IT'S INTENSE IN THESE COMMENTS.
IT IS INTENSE IN THESE COMMENTS.
I'VE GOT T MONEY 3004, HE SAYS
CROWDER AND JOHNSON, CROWDER AND
JOHNSON FOR THE 3X2.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU T MONEY 3004.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH $250.
>> CAM JOHNSON NOT A STARTER,
BUT WHO KNOWS?
MAYBE.
>> YEAH, MAYBE.
>> SO YOU HAD BOOKER AND
HOLIDAY?
>> BOOKER/HOLIDAY, CABBIE.
THAT'S WHO I'M ROCKING WITH.
>> SIDE BET, THAT COMBINATION
DOESN'T HIT?
>> SIDE BET?
WHAT'S A SIDE BET?
>> LIKE IF HOLIDAY OR BOOKER
AREN'T A PART OF A 3X2.
SO YOU'RE SAYING YES TO THOSE
GUYS AND I'M SAYING NO.
>> ALL RIGHT.
SIDE BET.
>> LITTLE 50 ON IT?
>> LITTLE 50.
>> I FEEL LIKE THE ODDS ARE I
SHOULD GET LIKE FIVE TO ONE AND
CABBIE SHOULD PAY ME.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
BECAUSE IT'S LIKE WHAT ARE THE
ODDS THESE TWO PLAYERS THAT I
NAME ARE GOING TO MAKE A
THREE-POINTER IN THE FIRST --
>> OKAY, TWO TO ONE.
I'LL GIVE YOU 100 AND, IF NOT,
THEN --
>> DO YOU GUYS THINK I SHOULD
TAKE THE BET OR NOT TAKE THE
BET?
YOU GUYS COMMENT AND LET ME
KNOW.
CABBIE, I'LL GET BACK TO YOU.
WE'LL GET THE SHOW GOING AND
I'LL GET BACK TO YOU.
WE'VE GOT TO SEE WHAT THE PEOPLE
THINK.
>> PLEASE DO.
IN THE LAST COUPLE OF SHOWS ON
TWITTER WE ASKED YOU WHO WAS
GOING TO WIN THE FINALS MVP.
THE FIRST TIME THE OVERWHELMING
RESPONSE WAS CHRIS PAUL.
THE NEXT TIME WE ASKED ON
TWITTER, THE OVERWHELMING
RESPONSE WAS GIANNIS
ANTETOKOUNMPO.
IN THE MIDDLE OF GAME FIVE C.J.
McCOLLUM DROPPED THIS ON
BASKETBALL TWITTER ABOUT THE MVP
CONVERSATION.
IF THE BUCKS WIN THE SERIES, HOW
MANY VOTES DOES KHRIS MIDDLETON
GET FOR MVP?
BRO BEEN SERVING AND CLOSING.
SO HE JUST DROPPED IT IN THERE.
A TON OF RESPONSES.
AND MAYBE HE'S ON TEAM PERKINS,
WHO HAS BEEN SAYING THAT KHRIS
MIDDLETON IS BATMAN AND GIANNIS
IS ROBIN.
BUT, ANYWAY, HERE IS OUR TWITTER
POLL, THE UPDATED ODDS FOR
FINALS MVP.
GIANNIS OVERWHELMING MINUS 430,
D. BOOK PLUS 650, PAUL PLUS 700.
WHO IS THE BEST BET TO WIN THE
MVP GOING INTO GAME SIX?
HAVE YOU CHANGED YOUR MIND?
WE LOOK HERE AT THE RESULTS,
GIANNIS 48% OF THE VOTE, DEVIN
BOOKER 27% OF THE VOTE COMING
OFF THOSE TWO HUGE 40 POINT
GAMES.
G-MONEY, WHERE ARE YOU AT?
WHERE DO YOU STAND ON FINALS
MVP?
>> CABBIE, I'M IN THE COMMENTS
RIGHT NOW AND THEY ARE BACK AND
FORTH ABOUT OUR BET.
I SEE A LOT OF TAKE THE BET AND
I SEE A LOT OF PEOPLE SAY DON'T
TAKE THE BET.
THEY'RE SAYING CABBIE IS
FINESSING YOU.
>> HOW AM I DOING THAT?
>> I'M JUST REPEATING WHAT
THEY'RE SAYING IN THE KMENCOMME.
WHAT I NEED YOU TO DO IS GET IN
THE COMMENTS AND TELL ME WHO IS
WINNING FINALS MVP AND TELL ME
WHY.
THE COMMENTS ARE EARNING
THEMSELVES $250 IN SNEAKER
MONEY.
ERIN, YOU LIKE CP3 EARLY ON.
HOW ARE YOU FEELING ABOUT THAT
NOW?
>> LIKE YOU JUST MENTIONED, I
HAD SAID AFTER GAMES ONE AND TWO
TO WAIT AND GET CP3 AT BETTER
VALUE IF THE BUCKS WERE ABLE TO
PUT UP SOME WINS.
NOW WE CLEARLY HAVE SOME VALUE.
CP3, I DON'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENED
TO HIM AFTER HIS FINALS DEBUT.
AT THIS POINT YOU OBVIOUSLY
WOULDN'T WANT TO BET GIANNIS AT
THIS PRICE MINUS 430.
I THINK GIANNIS IS DESERVING OF
FINALS MVP IF THE BUCKS DO WIN
TONIGHT.
OF COURSE THERE IS ARGUMENT
AROUND KHRIS MIDDLETON AND THAT
HE SHOULD ACTUALLY WIN IT.
FROM THE VALUE PERSPECTIVE I
WOULD TAKE CP3 HORS D'OR DEVIN .
I CAN'T BET ON GIANNIS AT MINUS
430 AT THIS POINT.
>> SEVEN TO ONE ODDS ON CHRIS
PAUL IS JUICY.
GOING BACK TO THE C.J. McCOLLUM
TWEET, THERE'S AN INTERESTING
ARGUMENT HERE, BECAUSE WHO DO
YOU VALUE MORE?
IT'S A BASEBALL ANALOGY, THE
STARTING PITCHER WHO TAKES YOU
THE FIRST SEVEN INNINGS AND THEN
THERE'S A MIDDLE RELIEVER AND
THE CLOSER COMES IN AT NINE?
SO IN THIS CASE, GIANNIS IS THE
STARTING PITCHER AND THEN KHRIS
MIDDLETON IS THE CLOSER.
THE COMPARISON IS CLOSER TO KOBE
AND SHAQ IN THE EARLY 2000s
WHERE SHAQ WOULD DOMINATE THE
GAME FOR THREE-QUARTERS AND KOBE
WOULD TAKE OVER IN THE FOURTH.
IT FEELS LIKE IN THIS SERIES
GIANNIS IS DOMINATING THROUGH
THREE AND A HALF QUARTERS,
MIDDLETON SPRINKLED IN AS WELL
BUT MIDDLETON GOES TO WORK IN
THE LAST FIVE MINUTES AND HITS
FROM ALL OVER THE COURT.
SO MY PERSONAL TAKE IS GIANNIS
ANTETOKOUNMPO AFTER GAME TWO,
AFTER THE SUNS WERE UP 2-0 IN
THE SERIES, THAT'S WHEN I JUMPED
IN AND I GOT GIANNIS AT PLUS 450
TO WIN MVP.
I'M RIDING WITH GIANNIS AND I
WOULD LOVE TO SEE HIM CLOSE IT
OUT TONIGHT FOR SELFISH REASONS,
BUT THE BEST BET I THINK IS
CHRIS PAUL AT SEVEN TO ONE TO
WIN FINALS MVP.
G-MONEY, WHERE DO YOU STAND ON
THIS PARTICULAR BET HERE?
BEST VALUE, FINALS MVP.
>> CABBIE, ERIN, LET ME SEE
WHERE THE PEOPLE STAND IN THE
COMMENTS.
I'VE GOT STEVE JOBLESS, HE GOT
THE GIANNIS GIF OF GIANNIS
DANCING AND HE SAYS EASY MONEY.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU STEVE JOBLESS.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
I HAVE GIANNIS WITH THOSE TWO
HUGE PLAYS AT THE END OF THE
LAST TWO GAMES, DESERVING OF AN
MVP.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
I'VE GOT NOT ZACH LaVINE, D.
BOOK, BEEN SAYING IT SINCE THE
SERIES FIRST STARTED.
HE'S GOING TO DROP 53 THIS GAME
AND WE THIN THE NEXT TWO.
I'M GOING TO STOP RIGHT THERE.
I'M GOING TO STOP RIGHT THERE
BECAUSE THE QUESTION IS, WHO IS
THE BEST BET FOR MVP, NOT WHO IS
ACTUALLY GOING TO WIN IT.
BUT THE BEST BET FOR MVP IS
ABSOLUTELY DEVIN BOOKER.
DO YOU NOT SEE THE VALUE?
HE ADDS VALUE NEXT TO HIS NAME,
PLUS 650, CABBIE, HE'S BEEN
ABSOLUTELY BALLING.
THIS SERIES IS NOT OVER.
LET ME REPEAT, THIS SERIES,
CABBIE, IS NOT OVER.
SO IT'S GOING TO GAME SEVEN?
>> IT MIGHT.
IT JUST MIGHT.
>> YOU JUST SAID THE SERIES IS
NOT OVER.
NOT JUST MIGHT.
YOU WERE PRETTY CONFIDENT IN
WHAT YOU SAID.
>> WE STILL HAVE TO PLAY
TONIGHT'S GAME, CABBIE.
THEREFORE, TECHNICALLY WHAT I'M
SAYING IS CORRECT, THE SERIES IS
NOT OVER.
>> ERIN, WAS THE WAY THAT HE WAS
POSITIONING IT LIKE HE'S
CONFIDENT THAT THERE'S GOING TO
BE A GAME SEVEN?
>> I FEEL LIKE WE ALL HAVE TO AT
THIS POINT, JUST CONSIDERING
THAT GIANNIS IS SO FAR OUT.
WE'RE KIND OF ASSUMING THAT.
>> THANK YOU, ERIN.
IT'S, LIKE, WHAT'S THE BEST BET?
THE BEST BET IS D. BOOK, HE'S
BEEN BALLING, PLUS 650.
THE SERIES ISN'T OVER, CABBIE.
>> ARE YOU BETTING ON A GAME
SEVEN?
WANT TO DO ANOTHER SIDE BET THAT
THERE WILL OR WILL NOT BE A GAME
SEVEN?
>> SEE, THE THING IS, CABBIE, WE
TALKED ABOUT SCOTT FOSTER.
WE TALKED ABOUT THAT ALREADY.
>> YOU CAN'T ACTUALLY --
>> LET ME THROW OUT THIS STAT.
ONLY FOUR TEAMS HAVE EVER
BOUNCED BACK FROM AN 0-2 DEFICIT
IN THE FINALS AND MIAMI HEAT
WERE THE FIRST TEAM TO WIN AFTER
COMING OFF THE DEFICIT IN 2006.
SO IT'S BEEN A WHILE.
>> IN THE MID-RANGE GAME.
>> IT'S VERY HARD TO DO.
SO WE ARE BASICALLY ASSUMING A
GAME SEVEN.
>> EVERYBODY IN THE COMMENTS ARE
SAYING THAT THE SERIES IS OVER.
THEY'RE SAYING IT'S GIANNIS, THE
SERIES IS OVER.
I DON'T THINK IT'S OVER.
WE'RE GOING TO SEE.
SHOT OUT TO ERIN ON YOUR STAT.
IT'S TIME.
CABBIE, I'VE GOT TO GIVE AWAY
SOME SHOES.
>> OKAY, GIVE AWAY SOME SHOES.
BUT I ALSO WANT YOU TO PUT YOUR
MONEY WHERE YOUR MOUTH IS.
GO AHEAD, GIVE AWAY SOME
SNEAKERS.
>> CABBIE IS HOSTILE WITH THE
SIDE BETS.
>> I NEED A LITTLE MORE ACTION,
I THINK IS WHAT I NEED.
I'M GOING TO JUMP INTO THE
PLAYER PROPS AFTER THE SHOW AND
GET TO BUSINESS.
ALSO, I NEED TO WIN SOME MONEY
BACK FROM GREG.
YOU DON'T KNOW THIS, ERIN, BUT
I'VE LOST TWO OR THREE BETS TO
GREG, SO I'M KIND OF CHASING
SOME OF MY MONEY BACK.
>> I UNDERSTAND.
>> HERE WE GO.
LET ME SEE, I'VE GOT -- I'M IN
THE COMMENTS.
JOE COOL 05 SAYS JRUE HOLIDAY,
IF IT WASN'T FOR HIM AND HIS
DEFENSE, GIANNIS WOULDN'T HAVE
GOTTEN THE GAME ALLEY-OOP.
HE HAS STEPPED IT UP IN EVERY
WAY.
THAT IS A GREAT TAKE, BUT HE IS
NOT WINNING MVP.
BUT SINCE IT WAS A GOOD TAKE AND
IT WAS FACTUAL, JRUE HOLIDAY HAS
BEEN BALLING, HE HAS BEEN
PUTTING THE CLAMPS ON CP3,
PLAYING HIM WELL, SO I'M GOING
TO GIVE JOE COOL 05, SHOUT OUT
TO YOU.
YOU'LL WALK AWAY WITH $250 AND
THAT WILL GET YOU SOME SHOES.
>> WELL DONE, SIR.
SO WE'VE JUST BEEN TALKING ABOUT
CHRIS PAUL AND SCOTT FOSTER.
HERE IS AN INTERESTING PARALLEL
WHEN IT COMES TO NARRATIVES.
THE LOGO, THE NBA LOGO IS IN THE
FORM OF JERRY WEST, ONE OF THE
NBA'S 50 GREATEST PLAYERS.
HE'S KNOWN AS MR. CLUTCH.
HE WENT TO THE NBA FINALS NINE
TIMES IN HIS CAREER, AND HE LOST
EIGHT.
HE'S STILL KNOWN AS MR. CLUTCH.
NOW, IN THIS ERA, CHRIS PAUL IS
WIDELY CONSIDERED THE MOST
CLUTCH PLAYER OF HIS GENERATION.
BUT IF THINGS DON'T PLAY OUT
TONIGHT, IF HE DOESN'T CARRY
PHOENIX TO A SEVENTH GAME, WILL
ALL OF THOSE CLUTCH PERFORMANCES
BE FORGOTTEN?
IT'S LIKE THIS IS ONE OF THE
TOPICS OF NARRATIVES WHEN WE GET
INTO -- WHEN WE'RE EVALUATING
GREATNESS, THESE ARE SOME OF THE
STORY LINES THAT ARE AT PLAY.
SO WILL CHRIS PAUL RE-WRITE
HISTORY AND CARRY HIS TEAM TO A
GAME SEVEN, OR MIGHT WE CONSIDER
HIM MORE OF A BUST THAN CLUTCH?
THE QUESTION IS TONIGHT, HOW
MANY POINTS IS CHRIS PAUL
SCORING, OVER OR UNDER 21 1/2?
G-MONEY, THAT IS THE LINE.
WHERE DO YOU STAND ON THIS
PLAYER PROP, OR DO YOU NEED TO
CHECK IN WITH YOUR PEOPLE BEFORE
YOU GIVE US YOUR ANSWER?
>> I'M DEFINITELY GOING TO HAVE
TO CHECK IN WITH MY PEOPLE.
I'M JUST CONFUSED THAT YOU'RE
CALLING CHRIS PAUL CLUTCH.
IN THE REGULAR SEASON?
>> HE IS A TEAM-CHANGER.
EVERY TEAM THAT CHRIS PAUL GOES
TO, THEIR WINNING PERCENTAGE
CHANGES BY LIKE 100 POINTS.
HE DID IT IN L.A., HE DID IT
WITH THE ROCKETS, WITH THE
OKLAHOMA CITY THUNDER, AND THE
PHOE
PHOENIX SUNS WERE A BUBBLE TEAM.
THEY DIDN'T EVEN MAKE IT INTO
THE PLAY-IN GAME.
THEY WON 26 GAMES AND NOW
THEY'RE IN THE FINALS, TWO GAMES
AWAY FROM WINNING THEIR
FIRST-EVER NBA CHAMPIONSHIP.
AND HIS CLUTCH STATS, WHICH I
DON'T HAVE THEM IN FRONT OF ME,
UNFORTUNATELY, BUT HIS CLUTCH
STATS ARE LIKE OTHER WORLDLY,
50%, 60%, 70%, WITH DAMIAN
LILLARD, UP IN THAT RANGE.
>> IN THE REGULAR SEASON?
BECAUSE USUALLY WE SEE CHRIS
PAUL GET PUT OUT BY THE GOLDEN
STATE WARRIORS YEAR IN AND YEAR
OUT.
AS FAR AS THE CLUTCH, I DON'T
KNOW ABOUT THE CLUTCH.
>> HOLD ON, WE'VE ALSO GOT TO
GIVE CHRIS PAUL PROPS FOR DOING
IT IN THE ABSENCE OF A SUPER
TEAM, UNLIKE YOUR GOLDEN STATE
WARRIORS.
HE'S DOING IT WITH DEVIN BOOKER
AND DEANDRE AYTON.
THEY GOT RID OF THE SUPER TEAMS,
BOTH L.A. AND IN BROOKLYN.
SO SALUTE TO CHRIS PAUL ONCE
AGAIN.
GO AHEAD ABOUT YOUR GOLDEN STATE
WARRIORS, THOUGH.
>> AYTON IS A NUMBER ONE PICK.
D. BOOK, SUPERSTAR STATUS.
I DON'T KNOW, CABBIE.
ANYWAY, CLUTCH, I WOULDN'T --
CLUTCH, I'M JUST HAVING A HARD
TIME CALLING HIM CLUTCH.
LET ME DO WHAT WE'RE HERE TO DO.
GET IN THE COMMENTS, GUYS, AND
TELL ME IF YOU THINK CHRIS PAUL
IS CLUTCH OR NOT.
>> THE COMMENTERS KNOW CHRIS
PAUL IS CLUTCH.
>> CABBIE, I JUST NEVER THOUGHT
OF CHRIS PAUL FIVE SECONDS LEFT,
WE NEED A BUCKET, CHRIS, GO GET
US A BUCKET.
THAT'S CLUTCH.
ERIN?
>> I AGREE WITH YOU.
I'M SORRY, I CAN'T CALL CHRIS
PAUL CLUTCH.
I'M SORRY.
>> ARE YOU GUYS SERIOUS?
>> CLUTCH?
>> IMPACTFUL, YES.
CHRIS PAUL IS IMPACTFUL.
>> CHRIS PAUL IS ONE OF THE
MOST --
>> HE'S NOT.
>> GUYS, LISTEN, ERIN, I KNOW
THEY PLAYED IN THE LAST ROUND,
BUT YOU'VE ALREADY FORGOTTEN
ABOUT HIS 41 POINT PERFORMANCE
AGAINST THE CLIPPERS, ZERO
TURNOVERS.
>> AGAINST THE BUCKS?
>> THE CLIPPERS ARE EVEN A
BETTER DEFENSIVE TEAM AND HE HAD
NO TURNOVERS.
>> I KNOW, BUT IT ONLY MATTERS
BECAUSE THEY'RE PLAYING THE
BUCKS RIGHT NOW.
>> GUYS, CHRIS PAUL IS CLUTCH,
OKAY.
THE AUDIENCE WILL TELL YOU IN
THE COMMENTS.
>> I MEAN --
>> YOU GUYS ARE NUTS IF YOU
DON'T THINK CHRIS PAUL IS
CLUTCH.
>> PEOPLE IN THE COMMENTS, HE
AIN'T CLUTCH, HE IMPACTFUL.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU -- I LOST THEIR
NAME, BUT SHOUT OUT TO YOU WHO
JUST SAID THAT.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
>> YOU'RE GIVING SOMEONE WHO YOU
FORGOT --
>> I'M TRYING TO FIND THEM.
OH, NOT NAJEE, SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
WHAT I NEED YOU TO DO IN THE
COMMENTS, LET ME KNOW IF HE'S
CLUTCH OR NOT CLUTCH.
TWO, LET ME KNOW, CHRIS PAUL, IS
HE GOING TO BRING IT BACK TO
HOUSTON?
IS HE GOING TO BRING IT BACK OR
IS HE GOING TO CHOKE TONIGHT?
LET ME KNOW, BASICALLY LET ME
KNOW IF HE'S GOING OVER OR UNDER
HIS POINTS.
LET ME KNOW.
IS HE GOING TO SHOW UP AND BE
CLUTCH LIKE CABBIE SAYS, OR IS
HE GOING TO BE CHRIS PAUL?
>> YOU GUYS HAVE FORGOTTEN ABOUT
GAME ONE AND TWO.
THE GUY IS ELITE.
>> ERIN, WHERE DO YOU STAND?
21 1/2 POINTS, CHRIS PAUL, OVER
OR UNDER?
>> HE'S AVERAGING 21 POINTS IN
THE SERIES, ONLY 15 WHEN PLAYING
IN MILWAUKEE.
SO BASED ON HOW HE'S BEEN
PLAYING ON THE ROAD, I'M
DEFINITELY GOING UNDER 21 1/2
POINTS.
PLUS HE'S ONLY BEEN ABLE TO PUT
UP 21 1/2 POINTS IN 89 GAMES
THIS SEASON, SO I'M TAKING THE
UNDER.
>> THAT'S A GREAT STAT.
ONE IN EVERY FOUR AND A HALF
GAMES, THAT'S PRETTY LEGIT.
ONCE THE ADJUSTMENT WAS MADE TO
PUT JRUE HOLIDAY ON CHRIS PAUL,
GUARDING HIM, THE SERIES HAS
CHANGED FOR CHRIS PAUL'S
OFFENSIVE PRODUCTION.
JRUE HOLIDAY, THIS IS THE REASON
THEY SENT THE FARM TO NEW
ORLEANS TO GET JRUE HOLIDAY,
THREE DRAFT PICKS AND BLEDSOE'S
CONTRACT.
HE WEARS THEM DOWN AND PICKS HIM
UP AT HALF COURT.
JRUE HOLIDAY IS A GREAT DEFENDER
AND WEARING DOWN THOSE
36-YEAR-OLD LEGS.
BUT THIS IS A LEGACY GAME, THIS
IS A LEGACY SERIES FOR CHRIS
PAUL.
THIS IS YEAR 16.
I'M NOT A BIG CLICHE GUY, BUT
HIS EFFORT LEVEL, HE'S GOING TO
LEAVE EVERYTHING OUT THERE ON
THE FLOOR TONIGHT.
I'M SAYING HE'S GOING OVER
21 1/2 POINTS.
IF YOU WANT TO GET IN ON SOME
LIVE BETTING OPPORTUNITIES, BET
CHRIS PAUL POINTS IN THE SECOND
HALF.
HE MIGHT HAVE 4, 6, 8 IN THE
FIRST HALF, BUT THEN HE PICKS IT
UP IN THE SECOND HALF.
GIVE ME THE OVER 21 1/2 POINTS
FOR CP3 TONIGHT.
G-MONEY, WHERE DO YOU STAND?
>> CABBIE, I'VE GOT THE
COMMENTS, AND I HAVE TO SAVE
THIS COMMENT BECAUSE IT'S SUCH A
GOOD TAKE AND IT KIND OF TALKS
ABOUT YOUR POINT AND CHRIS PAUL
BEING CLUTCH.
HE SAYS FRONT RUNNER FOR NOT
CLUTCH.
HIS TEAM HAS ALWAYS BEEN UP IN
THE SERIES DURING A CLOSEOUT
GAME.
I MEAN, CHRIS PAUL IS KNOWN FOR
BEING UP 3-1 A LOT OF TIMES, YOU
KNOW WHAT I MEAN, TEAMS COMING
BACK.
>> IT HAPPENED IN L.A., THEY
WERE UP 3-2 UNDER GOLDEN STATE
WARRIORS, BUT THEN HE INJURED
HIS HAMSTRING AND MISSED SHOTS
IN GAME SEVEN.
THAT WASN'T HIS FAULT.
I WAS WATCHING FROM THE BENCH.
>> ALL I'M SAYING, CABBIE,
CLUTCH.
PEOPLE IN THE COMMENTS, PEOPLE
THAT ARE WATCHING, CLUTCH, WHEN
I THINK OF THE WORD CLUTCH --
>> GO TO NBA.COM AND LOOK AT THE
STATS.
>> THE YELLOW KD 13, WILL SPLASH
ONE FROM THE CORNER.
CHRIS PAUL IS A WINNING PLAYER.
WHAT DO YOU HAVE?
>> I'VE GOT CXP, SAYS CP3 UNDER
WITH THESE IMPACTFUL, BUT HE HAS
BEEN TURNING THE BALL OVER SINCE
GAME THREE.
SPEAKING TO ERIN'S POINT, SHOUT
OUT TO YOU CX, YOU ARE WALKING
AWAY WITH A HOODIE.
ERIN, I'M RIGHT THERE WITH YOU.
I MEAN, SINCE THEY PUT MY GUY
JRUE HOLIDAY, HE'S BEEN
IMPACTFUL IN FORCING CHRIS PAUL
TO MAKE BAD PLAYS.
HERE WE GO.
I'VE GOT ONE MORE HOODIE IN ME,
CABBIE.
I JUST WANT TO GIVE OUT ONE MORE
HOODIE.
I'VE GOT LIAM O'CONNELL.
THIS IS MY GUY.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
CHRIS PAUL IS NOT CLUTCH.
IT'S HITTING OVER, BUT SUNS ARE
TAKING AN "L".
SO HE THINKS CHRIS PAUL IS GOING
TO COME OUT THERE AND TRY TO WIN
THE GAME FOR THE SUNS, BUT
EVENTUALLY THEY'LL TAKE AN "L".
LIAM, YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
CABBIE, I'M DONE.
CHRIS PAUL IS NOT CLUTCH.
THE PEOPLE HAVE SPOKEN.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU SEE.
ACTUALLY, I'VE GOT TO -- I'M
ROCKING WITH THE OVER.
I DO THINK CHRIS PAUL IS GOING
TO GO OUT THERE AND TRY TO WIN
THIS GAME.
IN ORDER FOR HIM TO DO THAT,
HE'S GOING TO HAVE TO SCORE.
SO MINUS 110, I LIKE THE OVER.
BUT IS HE CLUTCH?
I DON'T KNOW.
>> THIS IS RIDICULOUS.
YOU GUYS NEED TO GO ON CHRIS
PAUL YOUTUBE DEEP DIVES AND JUST
WATCH HIM WORK, WHETHER THEY'RE
SUPER CUTS OR SPEND SOME TIME ON
BASKETBALLREFERENCE.COM,
CLEANINGTHEGLASS.COM.
>> I LIKE HIM, BUT THE FINAL
VERDICT, HE'S JUST NOT A CLUTCH
PLAYER.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT STAT AGAINST
THE BUCKS THAT MAKES YOU THINK
THAT CHRIS PAUL IS CLUTCH IN ANY
WAY.
>> CLUTCH, I'M NOT PASSING HIM
THE BALL WITH FIVE SECONDS LEFT.
>> WHY NOT?
>> THEY'LL STEAL THE BALL AWAY
FROM HIM.
HE'S LIKE A LITTLE KID RUNNING
AROUND OUT THERE.
>> WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH TIME TO
CONTINUE THIS ARGUMENT, WHICH
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO HAVE OFF
CAMERA, OFF THE SCREEN.
BUT, LISTEN, THANKS, EVERYBODY,
FOR TAPPING INTO THE NBA FINALS
EDITION OF THE GROUP CHAT, LIVE
FROM THE BREACHE"BLEACHER REPOR"
THERE'S NOTHING HOTTER THAN MY
TWO CO-HOSTS HERE.
REMEMBER WHAT YOU LEARNED HERE
TONIGHT.
THERE ARE FIVE PLAYERS WHO CAN
POSSIBLY SCORE 20 POINTS
TONIGHT, SO JUST TAKE A SECOND
LOOK AT THOSE SCORING PLAYER
PROPS, LIKE THE CHRIS PAUL
OVER/UNDER, 21 1/2 POINTS.
THE BUCKS WERE DOWN 16 IN GAME
FIVE AND THEY CAME BACK TO WIN.
SO LOOK AT LIVE SCORING
OPPORTUNITIES OR LIVE BETTING
OPPORTUNITIES.
SO MUCH FUN.
THE 3X2, GET ON THE 3X2 PARLAY
IN THE FIRST HALF OR SECOND
HALF, LOCK IN WITH FANDUEL
SPORTSBOOK AND GET THE PLUS 410
ODDS BOOST.
WE HAVE MORE KICKS TO GIVE AWAY
AFTER THE SHOW.
G-MONEY, WE'LL TAP IN WITH HIM.
THE B/R BETTING ACCOUNT AND B/R
KICKS INSTAGRAM ACCOUNT OR THE
STREAM IN THE B/R APP, THOSE ARE
SPOTS WHERE YOU CAN GET A PAIR
OF FREE KICKS.
IF THE SERIES GOES TO GAME SEVEN
TONIGHT, IF IT'S EXTENDED, WE'LL
BE BACK ON THURSDAY FOR A FINAL
EDITION OF THE GROUP CHAT.
IF NOT, IF THE MIAMI BUCKS
HANDLE BUSINESS AND THEY WIN IN
FRONT OF THE DEER DISTRICT AND
THEY'RE ANOINTED CHAMPIONS FOR
THE FIRST TIME IN 50 YEARS,
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR TAPPING IN
WITH THE GROUP CHAT ALL SEASON.
WE APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT, THE
COMMENTS, AND ALL THE VIBES.
SUNSET VIBES, GOOD VIBES, ET
CETERA.
IF YOU WON A HOODIE OR SNEAKERS
TONIGHT, WE WILL DM YOU.
ENJOY GAME SIX.
G-MONEY, I WANT THAT VENMO RIGHT
AWAY AFTER THE GAME IF THE 3X2
DOESN'T HIT.
ALONGSIDE ERIN DOLAN AND GREG
IVORY, MY NAME IS CABBIE
RICHARDS.
WE'LL SEE YOU GUYS LATER.
WE ARE LEAVING THE GROUP CHAT.